بعد مزعم القوات الروسيه عن حصار مدينه
بخموت الاوكرانيه الرئيس الاوكراني فولو
فقد قوته في منطقه دنيتك باقليم دومباس
زياره تحدث فيها الجنود معربا عن امتنانه
لهم للدفاع عن اوكرانيا
اليوم يشرفني ان اشكركم ان اشكركم على
حمايه بلادنا وسيادتنا المهم هو الانتصار
بعد الانتصار سنعيد بناء واعمار كل شيء
بالتاكيد
بالتزامن مع ذلك يستمر القصف الروسي في
كييف الاداره العسكريه في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه اكدت ان القوات الروسيه شنت
هجمات ليليه بالطائرات المسيره على منشات
مدنيه وتسببت باندلاع حرائق وتضرر عدد من
المباني
مشاهد مماثله في مدينه زاكوريا
الاستراتيجيه حيث قصفت القوات الروسيه
مبنى سكنيا ما اسفر عن مقتل وجرح العديد
انه وضع مخيف جدا لم اعد اعرف حتى لما
يتقاتلون
عندما خرجت من المنزل كان هناك دمار ودخان
وصراخ وحطام وبعدها وصلت فرق الاطفاء
والانقاذ
البحريه من جانبها اعلنت انها سدت هجوما
بطائرات مسيره على مرفا سيبا ستوبول في
شبه جزيره القرم التي ضمتها موسكو عام